well I'm a pretty hardcore capitalist in
that sense I do believe you should act
in your self-interest and I believe
others should too as a man when I'm 23
24 and I'm single it is in my interest
to to sleep with as many beautiful women
as I possibly can that is 100 of my
interest and it's 100 of the women's
interests to get a commitment from the
best guy they can possibly get and
that's exactly I should be trying to do
yeah and if I'm unable and here's how
you destroy that argument by the way if
I'm unable to sleep with any women it's
not the women's fault right and if a
woman is not able to get a man to commit
it's not the man's fault because we have
to be equal here you want equality
there's equality people are like well as
a man you should do this it's like well
it's like well how do you feel about
these guys that are like really angry at
women we hate them wasn't it your fault
you're not sleeping with them no it's
like they're not attractive okay then
isn't it then likewise your fault that
you can't get a man to commit um